obrigado obrigado pelo pelo convite
voltar aqui a pisar este palco e
obrigado a marta eu ia pedir uma salva
de formas novamente com a marca por este
momento é obrigado a vida a vida não é
só o telex que é que é a técnica é feita
de momentos da vida ao fim ao cabo é
feita é feita de momentos que eu gosto
desta frase de joão estava dizendo que
eu disse que a vida é feita de momentos
não seria bom se tivéssemos presentes em
alguns deus muitos bons momentos maus a
que os menos bons como o nascimento de
um filho um sobrinho é nos momentos maus
já o tempo a perda de alguém que nós
facto que estamos mas o que acontece é
que se verifica e há um estúdio
apresentar provas apontam 47 por cento
do tempo nós não estamos presentes na
nossa mente está a pensar no futuro está
no fim do ano passado a fantasiar com
alguma coisa e criar agora vocês neste
momento estão a pensar num almoço estão
a pensar enfim uma coisa qualquer para
sabermos onde estamos e mais infância
que o plano que eu vou fazer e falar
passa muito por estar presentes aqui e
agora a então e ele pergunta que este
que chutassem alguém sobre o vosso lado
direito lado esquerdo e que tivessem uma
conversa um minuto uma coisa breve sobre
como é que estão neste momento como
estão agora neste momento thompson
triste estão estressados então como é
que estão neste momento com minutos
ontem alguém me encontrei com seu pai o
vosso awa um minuto apenas um rápido
socorro como é que estão neste momento o
cheque muito muito rápida ok
só mesmo como é que se encontra um metal
voz corpo como estava o orçamento neste
momento mas da manhã
seremos uma frase podem para incriminá
la com calma não precisando caló quando
viu assim como estava só de vamos fazer
aqui um exercício exercício mais
informações mas eu gostava de perceber
primeiro quem é quem está na audiência
negócio sempre começar com um uma
pequena sondagem quando vocês aqui nesta
sala tem como principal objeto trabalho
voz corpo seja por exemplo trabalha numa
fábrica precisam do corpo para digamos
assim o vosso corpo é o principal
instrumento de trabalho só para perceber
aqui uma pessoa duas a três pessoas
ok quatro pessoas quanto vocês têm a
mente como principal instrumento
trabalho sempre o investigador
estudantes só perceber a grande maioria
quanto vocês aqui com vocês aqui nesta
sala tem regularmente práticas de
higiene física tratar do corpo coisas
quando tomava banho lavar os dentes ou
então a gente olha quem o canto livre
uma pessoa juntava o braço 29 anos e
quanto você está em da mesma forma
práticas de higiene mental para tratar
da mente para ter um momento mais calma
mas ficava mais presente
coisas como yoga meditação mais fãs
tenho algumas pessoas quando vocês essa
prática que falaram e mais fãs
espero uma duas três quatro quatro
pessoas o que já ouviu falar do termo em
falar só para perceber quem é que nunca
ouviu falar do termo informação ok o
botafogo só enquadrar porque várias
pessoas que nunca ouviram falar
montou mais fãs não é mais como
capacitar todos nós já temos de estar
presentes aqui e agora sentir o corpo
por exemplo como é que tal voz dentro
grande do do pesqueiro mão direita ou à
esquerda consegue sentir como está agora
ou como está por exemplo o pensamento no
orçamento agora emoções
a capacidade está acima tudo presente
conectado por que está a passar em mim e
que o que está a passar a minha volta
automais só não é mais do que a
capacidade
está presente estar aqui e agora agora
estou aqui tá em cima de um palco
neto sentir os pés de pessoas olha pra
mim sinto o coração a bater porque é
normal estar em cima de um palco ficamos
mais corrido mais explorado
então esta primeira capacidade de estar
ligado a mim estar presente proprietário
aqui está a pensar o que vai ser o
almoço por exemplo que já ouvi dizer que
vai ser bom e também a capacidade está
ligada que está a passar na minha volta
a ter a capacidade de conectar aquilo
que se passa à minha volta
então como é que eu posso cultivar essa
capacidade que passa muito por trabalhar
a minha atenção a capacidade de perceber
onde é que eu quero pôr a minha atenção
e ao mesmo tempo poder cultivar chamada
meta atenção eu perceber que a minha
atenção se distraiu em voltar ao
presente se vai processar o investigador
isso pode ser muito útil porque permite
desfocar a vossa atenção por exemplo
investigação estão a fazer e perceber
que sempre que se estrearam contra coisa
que não tem nada a ver por exemplo o
facebook fazer uma coisa qualquer
importante para mim lá a mãe se constrói
em voltar a apresentar se esta
capacidade eu voltar constantemente aqui
e agora apresenta estava sobre a direita
neste momento a quarta a entrar o
terceiro
eu preciso eu constantemente verona que
estou sentido conectou e isso pode ser
cultivado várias formas uma delas é a
meditação palavra meditação tem muitas
ligações a religiosas esotéricas e tudo
mais mas ao mesmo tempo também já tem
muitas ligações científicas escolar e
várias universidades constante faro
estando fora oxford árvore e por aí fora
tem vindo a fazer grandes estudos que
mostram os benefícios de práticas como a
meditação que não sou mais o treino
mental mesmo se formos a origem das
palavras limitação não é mais do treino
mental é que vamos fazer um exercício
muito simples para percebemos como é que
eu posso cultivar essa capacidade está
presenta que agora quer uma infância
eles convidaram vamos sentar vamos
sentar aqui neste ano na famosa no
famoso caveirão do texas
e como é que então possa praticar esta
capacidade de deter o momento mais
presente
machucada é mais feliz a digamos assim
a primeira coisa que você convidaria
encontrar uma posição sentada que vos
permita estar duas coisas alerta e
relaxados ao mesmo tempo podem sentar lá
encostados à para trás e é um convite
ninguém é obrigado a fazer a primeira
vez vai fazer não faço há mais permitam
que os outros possam possam fazer então
por estar sentados atrás podem estar
sentados mais à frente e começou a
xingar estar sentado mais à frente
o mais importante de tudo é que eu possa
estar alerta porque é uma atividade que
vou fazer algo e relaxado ao mesmo tempo
não demasiado relaxados por passada no
caso
vamos ouvir alguém falar no banco e
trans ou mesmo até à frente
nenhuma ceará alerta porque isso vai
fazer tá focado nas minhas nos costas e
por fãs estão procurando essa posição
que permita estar alerta e relaxado
convido-os a rondar os ombros um pouco
para trás e para baixo e possam pousar
as mãos no colo nas pernas
a idéia é não estarmos preocupados nem
com um nem com as pernas nem com o
tronco nem com as mãos que o corpo possa
estar numa posição digna seja lá o que
significa pra vocês
convites a fechar os olhos se você for
confortável porque a idéia estamos
centrados na nossa experiência
senão não sentirem confortáveis
convidados a fazer pode ser abertos mais
focados mais ou menos um metro à frente
no chão e convidar você dar uma
inspiração mais profunda enchendo os
pulmões com a libertando o ar lentamente
talvez mais uma vez simplesmente
enchendo os pulmões com a libertando o
ar lentamente e permitindo agora que a
respiração possa encontrar um ritmo
natural seja não vamos a idéia não é
controlar a respiração não é deixar que
o corpo faça algo que já faz milhares de
vezes por dia
eclipse aumento nos mantém vivos em
estátua simples de respirar diz que a
vida começa com a primeira inspiração e
que acaba com a última último sopro tudo
o resto maio é simplesmente nossa vida
então vamos simplesmente honrar esse
processo se notar qual a entrar para
sair
a sensação física por exemplo no nariz
sentir que o ar por exemplo que entra é
normalmente mais frio que o ar que sai
por exemplo no peito sentindo o pleito
expandir a medida que inspiramos o
contrair a medida cria respiramos e ao
mesmo tempo tantas distrações barulhos
especialmente as distrações interior dos
nossos pensamentos estão todo o processo
passa por simplesmente notar que nossa
mente pensa da mesma forma que o coração
bate e voltará a sensação física da
respiração
sentindo a entrar para sair e chegar a
nenhum estado especial simplesmente
estar presente cultivar a capacidade de
saber que estou respirar saber que
aspira cada inspiração existe uma pausa
que é seguida de uma inspiração
outra pausa e saber também que no
orçamento vai pensar se vai extrair de
cada vez que nós lutamos e se
intencionalmente voltamos a atenção para
a respiração é como se fizéssemos uma
inflexão no nosso cérebro que pouco a
pouco vamos cultivando a capacidade de
estar mais presentes
voltando a entrar num crédito fazer nada
mais do que estar presente a respiração
e esta é a maneira fácil de praticar
mais formas mas existe outra ainda mais
fácil que é simplesmente não fazer nada
não precisamos da lado nenhum
simplesmente parar estar presentes os
sons lá atrás os pensamentos e notar que
nossa mente pensa seus pensamentos são
apenas como nuvens no céu
podemos observar os sons de respiração
e permitindo agora dar uma inspiração
mais profunda enchendo os pulmões com ar
e com voz tempo voltando lentamente à
atenção para a sala e se ao ganhador no
céu tudo bem se não apenas que estão
cansados então esta é uma forma muito
simples buscam hoje em dias prática em
hospitais mais de 700 hospitais no mundo
hoje em dia têm práticas mais fãs para
ajudar as pessoas a lidar por exemplo
com dor crônica com estresse a ansiedade
é praticada há escolas desde o
pré-escolar universidades por exemplo
zé no mba do iseg altamente conservador
o mba e sendo executas uma cratera de
mais fãs for business para que os
líderes do futuro possam ter momento
mais focada mais presente mais fluido e
todos nós
hoje em dia basicamente os nossos
trabalhos e aqui nesta sala apenas
quatro pessoas disseram que o principal
objeto já trabalhei é o corpo o resto
levantou todo o brasil comenta o convite
que eu gostava de fazer era hoje em dia
sabemos que nosso cérebro é altamente
plástico tem uma capacidade chamada
neuroplasticidade e que nós podemos
cultivar no orçamento da mesma forma
temos o ginásio cultivar o nosso corpo
podemos esperar cinco minutos por dia e
cultivar a nossa meta é sempre uma
história de um rabi am teve muito tempo
em retiro e que chegou a certa altura
londres se vê é a estação do comboio
cheio de pessoas acorreram a outro
assunto com bola e ela certa altura
civil para uma pessoa perguntando porque
quando a gente comer uma que você vai
correr no brasil e ainda correr atrás da
vida que eu perguntou você sabe que a
vida não vai atrás de si e que a única
coisa que você tem que fazer é parar
isso pra que a vida ao pai o meu convite
é convidados a parar dois minutos por
dia
simplesmente dois minutos para deixar
que a vida apae
e com isso permitir estar mais presente
e ver aquilo tudo as coisas boas e as
más os momentos que nos banhos
convidadas apenas a fazer uma coisa que
é agradecer à pessoa que vos deu atenção
existe se vocês forem procurar a atenção
dos recursos mais limitados que nós
temos muitas vezes estamos a falar com
alguém essa pessoa trabalha por
telemóvel está errado hoje em dia alguém
nos dar falta atenção por isso quando
alguém fizer atenção a isso que até o
presente mais vou ver se nós temos agora
por isso o convite
o fez com a vossa atenção às pessoas com
que os cruzam e agradeço àquelas que
ocupará em que vos deram atenção
muito obrigado